Jocelyn est presque comme une
réalité alternative si j'avais fait certains des mauvais
choix dans ma vie.
[Musique]
Je pense que je, vous savez, je
voulais au départ en faire
un conte de fées Dark Twisted avec l'
industrie musicale et tout ce que j'en sais
et l'accentuer.  et je
m'inspire de
films que Sam et moi aimons et
vous savez, créer quelque chose de spécial,
audacieux, excitant,
amusant,
vous savez, faire rire les gens,
énerver certaines personnes, vous savez, c'est juste que
je me suis reconnu dans Jocelyn, c'est tout ce que
vous m'avez demandé ouais.  euh,
une grande partie de Jocelyn est définitivement inspirée
par
euh mes expériences
euh
et par celles d'autres artistes
dont j'ai été témoin d'hommes féminins
euh
et presque oui, je me sens à nouveau très
chanceux d'avoir pris certaines des bonnes
décisions dans ma vie
euh, j'ai beaucoup de chance que tu saches que je suis ici, je
peux faire ce que j'aime avec les gens que j'aime
entourés des gens en qui j'ai confiance,
et Jocelyn est presque comme une
réalité alternative si j'avais fait certains des mauvais
choix dans ma vie et  euh
c'est presque c'est presque comme si
j'essayais de
montrer au monde ou d'enseigner aux jeunes artistes à
prendre les bonnes décisions peut-être
inconsciemment je ne sais pas
mais
ouais moi-même je ne suis pas Jocelyn bien sûr je
veux dire et euh
et Sam Sam vraiment  exploité là-dessus, je
veux dire,
euh, il est très observateur, tu sais, il
écrit ce qu'il sait, il écrit ce qu'il
voit,
euh et le
regarder sur grand écran,
il capture tout cela, euh c'est c'est,
tu sais, je ne peux pas, je peux.  Je ne
l'explique même pas
mais oui, certains d'entre moi sont à Jocelyn pour
répondre à ta question